what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the information that we
have all been waiting for the
confirmation for who will be the true
villain of this current arc in the black
lower story now we definitely had our
hunches but the most recent chapter
revealed a ton of useful information and
really connected all the dots in a big
way for that reason there is a ton of
stuff to talk about and that is exactly
what I will be doing right here in this
video if you enjoyed the black clover
content on this channel and you want to
see more please leave a like to let me
know it really does help and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications that way you won't miss
any of our future uploads you can also
check me out on Twitter and Instagram at
anime out Pro for all the latest black
clover news and updates and finally this
video will of course contain black
clover manga spoilers we're dealing with
the latest events in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned chapter 2 - 7 continues at the
exact point where the previous chapter
left off with austa forcing his way into
that space where the Queen of Hearts has
apparently been hiding the woman on the
throne of the heart Kingdom turns out to
be just a doll hasta is naturally
weirded out by this but he does feel
some sort of key coming from within this
space and then hasta is even more
shocked to see a woman snuggling the
beaver yes you heard that right and no I
am NOT making this up I don't know man
this isn't even be making innuendos for
the purposes of humor like the hasta
sword thing in the last chapter one of
the translations that I saw while doing
research for this video literally has
this woman saying snuggling the beaver
feels so good and to be honest the
official viscom translation is possibly
even worse I I don't even know let's
just move on okay so this woman who was
hidden I guess behind the throne was
actually snuggling a huge beaver
mattress thing and I guess she was
sleeping because she is apparently in
her
we learn right away that this woman is
very clumsy by Nature the water spirit
on Dean calls the woman Laura Pacheco
and Undine admonishes the woman for not
having changed out of her pajamas sakra
nost are confused about who this woman
is and whether she is really the ruler
of the heart kingdom by the way I know
that due to conflicting translations
there has been some confusion about
whether the person who uses the water
spirit on Dean is a princess or a queen
I've been saying Queen because it
appears that she is the one ruling the
kingdom and a princess is usually the
daughter of the actual rulers and not
the ruler herself but the official
viscom translation does use the term
princess and hold on because it's about
to get even more confusing the chapter
then switches back to the battle between
the Molson oil and FINRA versus Gaia
Gaia is impressed by the magic of his
opponents from the clover Kingdom but
their attacks were unable to do any real
damage to him he then immediately
catches up to the fleeing guests from
the clover Kingdom and Noel is shocked
by how quickly and effortlessly Gaia is
able to catch up to them Gaia then
suddenly does a complete 180 and instead
of attacking them he goes down on one
knee to apologize for attacking them in
the first place he says that he forced
them to have this battle in order to
test their magic level or magic tier as
we know from previous chapters
these tears go from nine which is the
weakest to zero which is the strongest
the princess queen beaver girl that
explains - hasta that battles between
mages aren't fought with numbers but by
the strength of their magic so basically
it doesn't matter how many mages team up
against one mage if that one mage has
significantly more powerful magic the
large group of mages still doesn't stand
a chance
beaver girl then takes this concept to
the national level explaining that
whichever country has the largest amount
of mages nearing tier zero is likely
going to be the strongest country on top
of that fighting demons
aka Devils requires magic that is tier 1
or higher I mean we know that this is
not the case when it comes to hasta but
asta ignores this and he just gets right
to the point he doesn't even ask what's
going on here and what's with the whole
almost drowning him thing he just tells
bieber girl that they have learned about
a demon's
that resides within the heart kingdom
and they were looking for information
about it when she hears this question
Ondine thinks to herself that only the
spirit Guardians like Gaea know about
the curse and she also thinks to herself
that they mustn't speak about the curse
to anyone but beaver girl just lifts up
her shirt again I am NOT making this up
and she reveals that there is a demonic
curse right on her abdomen she also says
that at this rate she will likely be
dead in a year and Ondine cries out in
outrage
scolding bieber girl for telling us
consecrate such top-secret information
so casually Valentin seems to accept
that this is just the type of person
that Bieber girl is and she then goes on
to explain to Sacre and asta that they
were brought here in order to test their
magic levels ie to determine which tier
their magic abilities fall into Undine
that confirms that the demon who cursed
Beiber girl is not other than Meggie
Kula by the way I realized that Bieber
girl's real name is Laura Pacheco but I
am not about to keep saying that over
and over again as Undine begins to
explain that the heart and clover
kingdoms have a common goal in defeating
Meggie Kula suddenly beaver girl
interrupts this serious conversation in
order to go water some plants apparently
we soon learned what she means by this
as beaver girl suddenly begins looking
at dozens if not hundreds of magical
screens showing different locations
within the heart Kingdom sacré realizes
that beaver girl is able to keep tabs on
the entire kingdom from here using these
magical screens and she's able to
control water around the entire kingdom
freely watering whatever plants and
trees she thinks need to be watered and
helping whatever people she believes
need help
Ondine then explains that loropetalum of
the power from the previous princesses /
queens of the heart kingdom confirming
that she has not lived for over 1,000
years herself but rather that she is
just one in a long line of heart Kingdom
rulers Undine then forces Beiber girl to
change her appearance putting more regal
clothes on her removing her glasses and
putting a large crown on her head but to
make things more confusing
Ondine then calls beaver girl the
all-knowing priestess or the
Nishant priestess okay wait a minute is
this girl the queen or a princess or a
priestess
she has been referred to as all three
depending on the translation and since
she has already inherited the power
passed on from the previous rulers and
since she appears to be ruling the
kingdom herself it would make sense to
call her a queen but most of the
translations including the official one
on viscom referred to her as a princess
I don't know I'm pretty confused about
this myself so how about this I made a
poll on my Twitter at anime uproar so
that you can choose how I should refer
to Laura Pacheco from now on should I
call her Queen
princess priestess or beaver girl head
over to my Twitter at anime uproar or
just click the link in the description
and whichever option wins the poll is
the option that I'm going to primarily
use from now on and be sure to follow me
on Twitter while you're at it for future
updates
Austan Sacre wonder whether beaver
girl's clumsiness is a result of the
demon curse but no apparently she's
always been this way and that is
interesting to say the least I mean she
is apparently the all-knowing ruler of
the heart Kingdom and a total klutz at
the same time Ondine then goes on to say
something very important she states that
the demon Meggie Kula resides within
that country and what country you ask
well the chapter then jumps to the demon
Kingdom where Locke Magna and Vanessa
are scouting out that rival kingdom the
same Kingdom that attacked the clover
kingdom multiple times in the past but
what they see there is stunning the
entire Diamond Kingdom army was
apparently defeated by one man a man who
kind of looks like crow lo Lucifer from
behind and a man who is clearly wearing
the symbol of the spade Kingdom on his
fur coat this man from the Spade Kingdom
is so strong that even Locke feels fear
for the very first time and he states
outright that he does not want to fight
this guy and that is how this pretty
epic chapter ends and to be clear we've
just had a bunch of important things
confirmed and a lot of key elements of
the plot just came together in a big way
we have confirmation that the ruler
heart Kingdom has been cursed by a demon
we also have confirmation that the demon
who cursed her was Meggie Kula the same
demon who is believed to have cursed
Noelle's mother finally we have
confirmation that Meggie Kula is the
same demon who resides within the Spade
kingdom and we now know that the Spade
kingdom and its demonic magic will be
the next major threat facing our heroes
in the black lower story as you'll know
if you've been following this channel
for a while for a few chapters now I
have been leaning towards the idea that
the heart Kingdom characters are not the
real villains and that all of this heart
kingdom stuff is just a world building
exercise before we get to the real next
villain Meggie Kula and the Spade
Kingdom in this chapter this was
seemingly confirmed and what's more this
Spade Kingdom and its soldiers have been
built up to be incredibly powerful one
single dude who kind of looks like
Corolla Lucifer from behind was able to
defeat an entire Diamond Kingdom army
and even the constantly smiling and
fight loving luck voltea was utterly
shook when he saw what this man can do
that is no joke this chapter was
definitely a game changer in a turning
point in the black lower story and we
now have a much better idea of where the
story is going for the foreseeable
future the next few stages of Austin's
journey are most likely going to be
leading up to an epic battle against the
demon McGee Cola and the mages of the
Spade Kingdom
I predict that we will also learn a lot
more about Noelle's mother Asti a Sylva
and how she became cursed by the demon
McGee Kula and I'm still sticking with
my theory that Asti a silva isn't really
dead but there is no confirmation of
that as of right now personally I really
enjoyed this chapter and I thought that
it did a lot to advance the plot I also
think that that beaver exchange is going
to go down in black clover meme history
let me know what you guys think do you
like to turn that the story has just
taken and crystalizing the true next
villain as Meggie Kula and the Spade
Kingdom or do you maybe feel that this
sudden turn of events was too jarring
they definitely went from Gaia and
Undine being villains to potential
allies really quickly feel free to share
your thoughts down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video you want to
see more black clover content right here
on the channel please leave a like to
let me know it really does help any
you happy to be new to anime uproar
please don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest black cover news and
updates and of course don't forget to
vote in that black clover Twitter poll
that I have going on right now I want to
give a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who make videos like this
one possible special thank you to all of
our pro hero to your patrons including
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson King's eldest on hell
cruise stealers poet Pablo
atropos Wraith very dolla beat karate
Gian Anatole Cassatt's ki TJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and I can't forget to once
the rise above all other clans a massive
thank you to all of our the one tier
patrons including in grata alone Adam
Merrimack makoto-kun and your voice Seth
if you enjoy our videos and you think
that they add some value to your life
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our page and exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]